Entre 1968 et 1970, un serial killer
surnommé le Tueur du Zodiaque
a assassiné au moins 5 personnes
dans la région de San Francisco,
et il est probablement responsable de
plusieurs dizaines d’autres cas non-confirmés.
Sa particularité était de narguer
les autorités
en envoyant des lettres aux journaux locaux,
lettres qui contenaient notamment
des messages codés de ce genre.
Et plusieurs de ces messages n’ont jamais
réussi à être décodés.
Le tueur n’a jamais été identifié,
et l’affaire est toujours officiellement
en cours depuis plus de 50 ans.
C’est alors qu’en 2001, un psychiatre qui
travaillait dans une prison californienne
a trouvé sur un des détenus des messages
comme celui-ci.
Il s’agit visiblement d’un message codé,
on imagine que chaque symbole correspond
à une lettre.
Et vu que ça se passe en Californie,
ça faisait sérieusement penser
à l’affaire du Zodiaque.
Le psychiatre qui avait trouvé le message
a alors eu l’idée de le soumettre
au mathématicien Perci Diaconis,
qui travaillait comme Professeur
de statistiques
à l’Université de Stanford, juste à côté.
Diaconis à l’aide de ses étudiants a alors
mis au point une méthode
assez redoutable qui a permis de décoder
les messages de la prison.
Et la méthode est tellement puissante
qu’elle fonctionne avec presque n’importe
quel texte codé de cette manière.
Et c’est de ça dont on va parler
aujourd’hui.
Pour coder un message, il existe
tout un tas de méthodes,
j’ai déjà eu l’occasion de faire un
épisode sur le sujet.
On peut par exemple décaler les lettres
de l’alphabet d’une certaine quantité.
Par exemple le A devient devient D,
le B devient E, le C devient F, etc.
C’est simple mais ça n’est pas très efficace,
il n’y a que 26 possibilités,
et donc ça va très vite de tout tester
et de regarder ce qui marche
pour décoder le message.
Une méthode beaucoup plus robuste,
c’est ce qu’on appelle:
le chiffrement par substitution.
Alors petit point vocabulaire, j’ai tendance
à utiliser indifféremment
les termes coder/décoder,
voire crypter/décrypter,
mais chez les puristes il faut savoir
que les termes officiels
c’est chiffrer/déchiffrer.
Et donc on parle de méthode de chiffrement.
Et donc le chiffrement par substitution
consiste
à remplacer chaque lettre par une autre,
mais sans logique particulière.
Vous pouvez tout mélanger, et vous pouvez même
remplacer par des symboles si ça vous amuse,
comme sur le message de la prison
dont on a parlé.
Un code par substitution est beaucoup plus
difficile à percer.
Il faut dire qu’il y a un paquet
de possibilités.
En gros il y a 26 possibilités
pour coder le A,
il en reste 25 pour le B, 24 pour le C,
etc.
A la fin ça fait factorielle de 26,
soit presque un demi milliard de milliards
de milliards de possibilités.
Donc même avec un ordinateur, il n'est
absolument pas question de tout tester.
Une manière assez intéressante d’attaquer
ce genre de code,
c’est d’utiliser les statistiques.
On sait par exemple que dans la langue
française, le E est la lettre la plus courante.
On peut donc imaginer que dans un message dont
vous savez qu’il est en français,
le symbole ou la lettre qui revient le plus
représentera le E,
et on peut faire pareil avec
les autres lettres.
Ici j’ai pris un texte français classique,
du côté de chez Swann de Proust,
et j’ai analysé la fréquence de chaque
lettre.
Vous avez les chiffres ici,
le plus fréquent
c’est le E bien sûr, suivi du A,
du I, du S, etc.
Et donc à partir de ça, si j’ai un message
dont je sais qu’il est en français,
je peux essayer de deviner les lettres
les plus fréquentes,
par exemple ici le P représente
probablement le E,
et progressivement arriver à craquer le code.
Ça c’est bien, mais ça ne marche que si
le message codé est suffisamment long,
pour pouvoir faire vraiment des statistiques
fiables et représentatives.
J’ai fait quelques essais, et même avec des
textes de plusieurs milliers de caractères,
c’est très difficile d’identifier
automatiquement plus que quelques lettres,
et donc il faut forcément une intervention
humaine derrière
pour tâtonner, reconnaitre des mots, etc.
Alors que la méthode dont on va parler
aujourd’hui,
elle marche quasiment à coup sûr,
et de façon automatisée
dès que le message fait plus
d’une vingtaine de mots.
Alors voyons le principe.
Imaginez que vous travailliez avec un ami
à décoder un message,
et que soudainement votre pote vous dise:
"ça y est j’ai trouvé le code".
Comment vous faites pour vérifier
s’il a effectivement trouvé?
Ben vous traduisez le message, imaginez
que sa traduction donne ça.
Là vous allez dire à votre pote:
« Ça marche pas ton truc,
tu vois bien que c’est pas du français",
on reconnait pas les mots,
même si vous ne considérez qu’un tout petit
morceau du résultat.
On voit bien que ça, ce n’est pas le genre
d’enchainement de lettres
qu’on trouve en français, on n'a jamais
un M suivi d’un Z puis d’un H,
c’est assez peu plausible que ce soit
effectivement la bonne traduction.
Ce que ça montre, c’est que si on propose
une traduction décodée du message,
rien qu’en regardant les enchainements
de lettre,
on peut lui attribuer un certain niveau
de plausibilité.
Là c’est pas du tout plausible
que ce soit la bonne réponse,
alors que là, c’est mieux, c’est pas encore
ça, mais c’est plus plausible,
on reconnait certains enchainements de
lettres assez typiques du français.
Eh bien cette notion de plausibilité, on peut
lui donner un sens mathématique précis.
Pour ça on va considérer les probabilités
d’enchainement de lettres dans la langue
française.
Par exemple après un A, qu’est-ce
qu’on trouve?
Eh bien si je reprends le texte de
« Du côté de chez Swann »
je peux faire les stats et voilà
ce que je trouve.
Après un A on a presque 26% de probabilité
de trouver un I,
16% de trouver rien, c’est à dire que ce soit
la fin du mot,
14% de trouver un N, etc. et seulement
0.2% de trouver un J par exemple.
Et je peux faire ça aussi pour savoir ce
qu’on trouve après un B, un C, etc.
Au total, je peux construire un tableau
de probabilité
pour tous les enchainements de lettres
possibles.
L’image que vous voyez ici, c’est
une représentation graphique de ce tableau,
plus on va vers le jaune, plus
les enchainements sont probables.
On retrouve des trucs classiques
comme le fait
qu’après un Q on a presque toujours un U,
après des consonnes, c’est presque toujours
des voyelles, le E étant la plus fréquente,
et après un E, c’est assez souvent un espace,
c'est-à-dire la fin du mot.
Il y a un petit truc amusant ici,
c’est le fait
que le W soit presque toujours
suivi par un A,
ça c’est parce que j’ai utilisé
« Du côté de chez Swann »
comme texte de référence pour
mes statistiques,
comme le mot Swann apparait souvent, ça crée
un petit biais mais c’est pas très grave.
Bon qu’est-ce qu’on va faire de ce tableau?
On va s’en servir pour calculer la plausibilité
d’une proposition de traduction.
Pour ça on prend les mots de la traduction
proposée,
on regarde chaque enchainement de lettre
et on multiplie les probabilités associées
les unes après les autres.
Si on a des enchainements de lettres
très improbables,
on va multiplier des nombres très petits,
alors que si les enchainements sont naturels
en français,
on va avoir quelque chose de moins petit.
Et donc, à toute suite de caractères on peut
attribuer un score de plausibilité
qui nous indique en gros si cette suite
ressemble à du français ou pas du tout.
Et pour ça pas besoin de connaitre les vrais
mots du français,
juste les enchainements de lettres.
Petite remarque pour les matheux:
pour mon score de plausibilité,
je vais en fait prendre le logarithme
de la probabilité multipliée
pour avoir un nombre pas trop petit, et je
vais normaliser par le nombre de caractères.
J’obtiendrai alors un score qui se
balade typiquement
entre -6 et -8 pour des textes absurdes,
et pas loin de – 2 pour des vrais
textes en français.
Grâce à cette mesure de plausibilité,
on peut automatiser la recherche du code
qui va permettre de déchiffrer un message.
Voilà comment on va faire.
Ici j'ai pris un message codé,
incompréhensible
et on va partir d'une proposition initiale
pour le déchiffrement.
Ici j'ai construit ma proposition initiale
en analysant les fréquences.
Le P est la lettre la plus fréquente,
je le traduis donc par un E, etc.
Si j'applique ça, j'ai un message
qui est du charabia,
mais avec des enchaînements de lettres
qui semblent assez raisonnables,
je peux calculer sa plausibilité,
c'est -3,66.
Alors, un petit point de détail,
ne vous étonnez pas
que les plausibilités soient négatives,
c'est juste lié à ma manière de calculer,
retenez qu'on va essayer de la faire
augmenter et d'atteindre environ -2.
Pour faire ça je peux essayer de permuter
deux lettres au hasard dans mon code
par exemple je vais inverser
le code du L et du S.
Avant le L se traduit en A et
le S reste un S,
si j'inverse, le L se traduit en S
et le S en A.
En appliquant cette nouvelle proposition,
j'obtiens une nouvelle traduction,
pas trop différente dont je peux calculer
la plausibilité,
on trouve -3,26 c'est mieux,
ça se voit d'ailleurs, on a
des enchainements meilleurs.
Sur le premier mot par exemple LAIS
c'est mieux que LSIA
Imaginons plutôt une autre permutation,
si à la place je permute le code
du I et du P,
avant le I donnait un W et le P un E,
maintenant le I donne un E et le P un W.
La nouvelle plausibilité c'est -5,63
beaucoup moins plausible,
ben c'est logique, maintenant j'ai des W
partout
dans des mots de deux lettres,
c'est assez absurde.
Grâce à cette simple méthode, on peut
faire des permutations,
et utiliser le calcul de plausibilité
pour essayer d'améliorer notre traduction.
Une façon assez simple de progresser,
c’est de dire que
si ça améliore effectivement la plausibilité,
je conserve la permutation de lettre
que je viens d’essayer,
et si ça la dégrade je la rejette.
En répétant ça un grand nombre de fois,
on va obtenir des traductions
de plus en plus plausibles.
Alors c’est bien mais c’est pas suffisant.
Si on fait ça, on arrive en général
vers une solution qui n’est pas forcément
la meilleure, un truc plausible
mais pas assez.
Une astuce pour s’en sortir, c’est,
d’utiliser une procédure plus subtile
qui s’appelle l’algorithme de Metropolis.
En gros la motivation c’est la suivante:
imaginez que vous soyez sur une colline
et que vous vouliez trouver le point
le plus bas de la région.
Une solution c’est d’essayer de toujours
descendre,
mais vous risquez de vous retrouver coincé
dans une vallée
qui n’est pas forcément la plus profonde
de toutes.
Techniquement on appelle ça un minimum local,
pour trouver le vrai point le plus bas,
il faut certes descendre quand on peut,
mais aussi accepter de remonter
un peu de temps en temps.
C’est ce que fait l’algorithme de Metropolis.
Si une permutation dans le code permet
d’améliorer la plausibilité, on la conserve.
Et si elle dégrade la plausibilité, on va
l’accepter avec une certaine probabilité
à condition que la dégradation
ne soit pas trop importante.
Et je vous passe les détails, mais
cette méthode permet assez rapidement
de trouver le bon code, qui va presque
automatiquement déchiffrer le message.
Voici un exemple ici: en une fraction
de seconde,
on fait quelques milliers d’itérations
et on arrive à une solution
très plausible.
En général il reste un ou deux ajustements
à faire manuellement,
mais c’est très simple, le plus dur est fait.
Si on veut, on peut raffiner l'algorithme
en comptant automatiquement
le nombre de mots français corrects
qui apparaissent
et s’en servir pour améliorer encore.
Et ça marche super bien!
Et pourtant le message n'est pas hyper long,
là j’ai codé le truc en Python
d’une façon pas du tout optimisée,
et ça prend quelques secondes maximum,
et ça fonctionne sur des messages codés
même s’ils ne contiennent qu’une vingtaine
voire une quinzaine de mots.
La méthode que je viens de vous décrire,
elle a donc été mise au point
par Perci Diaconis et ses étudiants,
et elle est a bien marché
pour le message du prisonnier californien
dont je vous ai parlé au début.
Et ce qui est assez étonnant, c’est
qu’une fois décodé, le message était
un mélange d’anglais avec des expressions
en espagnol et de l’argot de prison,
mais ça a fonctionné quand même.
Et bon, a priori rien à voir
avec le Zodiaque.
Si vous êtes un tueur en série et que vous
voulez utiliser un code par substitution,
faites gaffe parce qu’avec cette méthode
qu’on appelle donc
Markov Chain Monte Carlo
ou MCMC pour les intimes,
eh bien c’est assez facile à casser.
Il existe quand même quelques moyens de
compliquer l’affaire,
et c’est sans doute pour ça que les messages
du tueur du Zodiaque
n’ont pas été tous complètement décodés.
Une première technique c’est d’utiliser
plusieurs symboles différents pour une même
lettre, par exemple pour le E.
Ça évite qu’un symbole apparaisse trop souvent
et qu’on devine facilement que c’est le E.
Ça complique un peu, mais la méthode MCMC
s’en accommode assez bien.
Dans le même genre j’ai récemment soumis
une énigme à un ami, (salut Éric)
et j’ai écrit un message qui ne contenait
pas du tout de E.
Oui je suis un peu vache.
Sinon un truc radical que fait le Zodiaque
c’était d’enlever tous les espaces.
Ça complique beaucoup l’estimation
de la plausibilité,
puisque ça conduit à des enchainements
de lettres
qui sont normalement totalement improbables,
comme ici en anglais un G suivi d’un P.
Vous pouvez aussi virer des lettres de temps,
faire intentionnellement des fautes
d’orthographe ou de codage,
ou bien ajouter des séquences de lettres
qui ne veulent rien dire.
Si votre interlocuteur qui a le code,
ça ne le gênera pas trop,
par contre ça brouillera complètement
les estimations de plausibilité.
Après, le Zodiaque c’est
encore plus compliqué.
Un de ses messages a d’ailleurs été déchiffré
très récemment en décembre 2020,
et une des astuces était qu’une fois décodé,
les mots se trouvaient en fait écrits
en diagonale
avec un mouvement comme le cavalier
aux échecs.
Assez diabolique le gars!
On ne sait pas encore si ça va relancer
l’affaire,
et notamment permettre de décoder
le message le plus critique,
celui où il dit « My name is… »
Il y a des tentatives mais à ce jour,
le FBI n’a officiellement rien conclu.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui,
si ce sujet vous plait,
j’avais fait déjà un épisode
qui montrait
comment on pouvait inventer des mots
plausibles avec le même genre d’analyse.
Cet épisode « La machine à inventer des
mots » est peut-être
un de mes préférés de toute la chaine,
ou en tout cas un de ceux dont
je suis le plus fier.
À la fin j’ai même écrit un poème un peu
Oulipo avec la technique, donc allez voir ça.
Comme toujours, faites vos offrandes
à la sainte trinité de l’algorithme Youtube:
abonnez vous, partagez, mettez la cloche,
et puis nous on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo.
À bientôt!
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -